antenne 2 et philips vous présente le
bar de la plage
l'émission d'été 2-1 dix ans
oh
[Musique]
le vieux piano de la place de joux
console console études de piano de la
plage à des clients dont l'habitude et
de danse
dimanche les autres jours ça sur les
planches
dans la mer qui se souvient il rêve sont
ses talents de son tour battue de ma
cachette et soudain de rang tremblante
en lui chemin inverse
c'est inouï tout ce que je retourne
comme cette musique jali mais pour me
fait du mal
me fait du bien lancée adieu vieux piano
bonsoir bienvenue au bar de la plage
avec ceux qui le dis ce soir il le dit
pour la première fois à référé ne me
touche pas et maintenant
confessions d'un marchand d'herbes de
provence la plage à la page
andré bercoff ivres de livres les
aventures de lolo chez les blaireaux du
bord de l'eau très chaud pour les petits
marie leurs actions de maryse et le
barman qui ne l'ouvrent cabot messiaen
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
à
[Musique]
[Rires]
ce soir gagner un baladeur cd philips
répondait en tapant 36 15 codes à 2 à la
question suivante quel est le vrai nom
de patricia carli
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir jacky bonsoir monsieur voilà ce
matin je me suis levé un peu plus tôt
que d'habitude monsieur c'est bien je me
suis regardé dans la glace qu'on en près
d'une minute
courageux mais j'ai remarqué que je
ressemblais de plus en plus à jean
lefebvre j'ai peur de quoi jacky
je ne sais pas monsieur j'ai peur de
devenir drôle
rassurez-vous jacky vous ne courait
aucun risque merci monsieur
[Musique]
à
pour
et bon
si content d'être là car ça fait quatre
ans que j'ai pas pris de vacances
et puis c'est formidable bruyas maire a
dit moi il ya deux personnes quand même
qui sont mort de rire à cause de toi
c'est incroyable la première dame qui
est morte de rire
c'est au théâtre des variétés on joue
une pièce qu'ils s'appelaient je veux
voir mioussov elle rit aux éclats était
dans les premiers rangs d'un dimanche et
tout d'un coup j'ai vu que cela
et puis est elle si un peu évanoui et on
l'a sorti et à l'entracte j'ai demandé
ce qu'elle avait on n'a pas voulu me le
dire
et à la fin du spectacle madier les mots
et les morts c'est à dire la pauvre
femme
ça ne fait rire les rôles ces
désagréments en relayant et elle avait
de la ce et en riant elle s'étaient tous
fait la deuxième personne
c'était au théâtre il ya à peu près un
an
il ya une dame qui y avait des gens qui
demandaient des dédicaces et il y avait
une dame qui était là je suis de voler
une dédicace noël
je voudrais vous parler personnellement
et souvent défaut l'un est bon tout le
monde feint résume christian malard elle
me dit je voulais voir de visu
je suis pourquoi parce que mon mari
aimant à cause de vous alors c'est très
bien que tu me réponds je je dis à vous
devez m'en vouloir
sinon avec 40 ans son mari à une
cinquantaine d'années
elle me dit non mon mari était cardiaque
on y avait eu un fils qui passait de
lautner mais nous fâchons pas et il rit
aux éclats tout d'un coup animaux l ai
dit je l'aimé beaucoup mais j'ai une
conservation il est mort en riant et tu
veux répondre et enfin à 10 mois à tuer
leurs cordes man france est détourné et
arrêtent pas là tu reprends les jumeaux
mais après tu repars en tournée car
c'est un petit franc suisse riche
belgique
j'ai bien touche du bois parce que
toutes les pièces que j'ai joués on les
a joués minimum 800 fois d'avoir presque
je suis paresseux tamment comme ça je
suis obligé d'apprendre des nouveaux
textes et puis plus on joue plus on
améliore plein trouve des trucs et c'est
ça qui fourmillent hameau vital au
théâtre plus que au cinéma parce que si
un effet ne portent pas tu peux le
rectifier alors qu'au cinéma c'est sur
le véhicule
as tu dis je préférais quand j'étais
fauché parce que maman je me suis vu
prendre de vacances ça fait longtemps
que tu as pas pris de vacances jean
quatre ans ah oui c'est beaucoup mais
c'est quand même curieux parce que je
suis en vacances depuis
une dizaine de jours 1 je suis un peu
pour mais tu fais quoi alors quand en
vacances quand je suis en vacances
j'ai une très grande qualité et
je suis paresseux et ses carrés ce jeudi
encore dit que les paresseux c'est un
défaut ya plus un paresseux je ne
m'ennuie jamais eu pas de nuit dans les
boîtes c'est un peu si je les boîtes
j'ai fréquenté beaucoup mais j'aime bien
les boîtes mais papa trop long
parce que dans une boîte on n'a plus de
rapport
ça fait tellement de bruit que tu peux
pas je ne peux pas parler ici du pain et
dans alors qu'est ce que tu as fait hier
quoi je dis qu'est ce que tu as fait
hier un juge avait de la fièvre
non qu'est ce que ça va bien pour
draguer pour draguer en plus on drague
et c'est bien parce que ça faisait pas
besoin de parler tu as découvert tahiti
avec fernand raynaud et tu as dit là bas
chaque grain de sable me rappelle un
souvenir pourquoi tu as passé du temps
tu as laissé ton coeur à tahiti là bas
oui je suis un essai à gérer et et je
suis resté deux mois et je crois que
c'est un des plus beaux souvenirs de ma
vie puisque le père de fernand était
tombé amoureux une tahitienne de 22 ans
celui avait 72 ans mais attends ce qui
est formidable c'est que la tahitienne
c est amoureux c'est pas par intérêt
parce qu'elle aime quelqu'un est le père
de fernand des qui a connu sept filles
on le voyait plus quand on paye est dans
la rue on aurait dit un drogué et dans
la rue thiers et fernand aidé par dix et
eddy bonjour je n'y répondrai après les
fermes en guinée t'as vu
cette co na va me tuer mon père
au moment de partir tout le monde était
là sauf le père de fernand raynaud et
fernande il l'hydravion partira pas pour
trouver mon père ah oui il y avait
quatre gendarmes à l'époque dans l'île
on a fait pour le lien on a retrouvé le
père qui pleurait la petite chlorés du
lest
pourquoi tu ne l'ès pas ça m'a fait
beaucoup de peine
je veux pas qu'ils créent vie civile
alors même si très vite il va il va
crever d'un nouvel mort n'est pas vu
bien sûr et l'a emmené de force
grady moi quand tu étais là bas et
ailleurs derrière tu adores regarder des
fonds se doit regarder des fonds sans
masquer son bétail synthétique branche
et par et pas de pêche
jallet un endroit où on allait j'avais
un copain d'haïtiens qui connaissait
tous les maisons quoi et il y avait un
dauphin qui venait tous les jours qui se
mettaient contre moi et je caressais toi
et tous les jours il venait lui donner
du poisson à la main comme ça et il
savait l'heure à laquelle j'arrive et ce
qu'ils ont mais là alors quand tu vis à
quoi tu te dis c'est très vive sous
l'eau c'est pour ça que chez toi tu as
cette immense aquarium 1 avec de l'eau
de mer et poissons de et les poissons tu
leur donnes le nom de tes amis c'est
vrai ouais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
règles ajoute à celle affichée toutefois
je sais pas beaucoup
oui balutin pasquet agl de balutin mon
poisson et le dis moi cette histoire
d'aquarium ça fait il coûtait cher parce
que tu t'es fait arrêter à la frontière
espagnole pour trafic de drogue
1 ça que tu saches à se former non
j'avais je suis allé au brésil conte
avec belmondo et j'ai trouvé des simples
du sable blanc mais blanc plus blanc que
cinq mois j'ai dit aux gens emmène pour
mon aquarium rue je me met du sable du
sable dans des petits sacs en plastique
c'est ce que et puis j'arrive à
l'aéroport indira ils s'en souviennent
encore ces diables c'est à orly je vous
ma valise et puis ils voient les petits
sacs de sable 1 qu'est ce que c'est et
sa justice et du sable il appelle le
chef y avait monsieur lefebvre il ya du
sable et ramène du sable j'en veux à
tous les paquets je sais pas j'en ai dit
qu'il y aura 15 kg ils ont repris par
exemple vérifier tous les paquets rien
il était un chef c'est pas de la drogue
didon et si c'est vrai pour les dégoûter
de la drogue tu l'auras organisé une des
six partis qui les a rendus malades
c'est vrai ça je mets ta range est
quelqu'un qui revient peut ne pas dire
le nom
un acteur connu j'y vois là moi j'ai
peur pour mes filles de la drogue alors
j'aurai vous que ce soir on vient de
chez toi et puis on fait une partie de
moi je n'ai jamais pris alors il dit jje
peur pour mes enfants dit tu as raison
est la grosse production
il ya vu le champagne
et je dis à mes filles elles ont validé
ensemble ils trois filles et puis après
je vous réserve une surprise mais sans
votre mère mais qu'est ce que tu as
sauvé ce je vous dirai plus tard on la
vit et puis maintenant on va aller on va
les fumées du h
c'est papa tu fumes uh vous allez viens
avec moi et j'avais dit à mon copain tu
leur fais rôle des cigarettes mais que
du nuage
kamala comme des bêtes alors être sont
arrivés ils ont fumé village moi j'en ai
fumé un peu alors que je fumais pas
elles ont été malades
moi aussi malade comme des mets et tu
vois après elles m'ont dit papa tu as eu
raison
dis moi alors on a parlé des du travail
des poissons de défis on va écouter une
chanson et puis on va aller parler des
femmes sur la plage tous les deux
d'accord il y en aura on va voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
jacques les fous qui m'intéresse
[Applaudissements]
douleur ashton je m'en fous
[Musique]
j'en parle
avec un ami qui fait là
sophie dit ma vie
réseau
dieu que c'est bon
reste à tout le reste je m'en fous
[Musique]
bien que les filles qui m'a des açores
[Applaudissements]
le reste c'est du super flou
où
j'avais quoi six ans passés comme ça
cette envolée
je ne pense qu'à ça
mes bras ya les films intérêts
[Musique]
je m'en fous
wallace
jacques les filles qui me sert à ça
[Musique]
c'est du superflu
et
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a en elle sans fond de grâce tant
de beauté ce qu'on leur fasse l'amour
j'en ai fait valoir
tout cela
[Musique]
lara stone
bien que les filles
ce qui maintenant
[Musique]
lucifer flou
dit moi quand tu es tu étais petit à 18
mois à l'âge de 18 mois tu as eu la
poliomyélite oui et tu es resté
appareiller jusqu'à l'âge de 10 ans 10
ans et c'est là qu'il a commencé à faire
l'andouille pur jus pour attirer la
sympathie les gens j'ai cité un drame
dans mon enfance parce que les enfants
entre eux sont très dures et
devant le traité de boiteux raté le
bateau je voyais tous et tous mes
copains qui jouent au tennis qui jouait
à au football et moi je restais toujours
à l'école dans un coin j'étais là j'ai
admiré parce que je ne pouvais pas le
faire mais il me laissait tomber un peu
et instinctivement pour les attire à moi
je commence à faire le coup
il ya une histoire formidable c'est
l'histoire de temps d'autant premiers
amours de vacances quand elle avait 9
ans à audresselles dans le pas de calais
et là il y avait cette petite qui
s'appelait se fait marie thérèse qui
avait la ville en face de l'actuel et
tous les matins quand tu ouvrez les
fenêtres la voyait le voile et neil ont
fusé des sourires et puis un jour
tamer organisé une soirée cinéma est
alors la justice faisait regarder
et puis dès que la lumière s'est éteinte
a pris la main et le lendemain qu'est ce
que vous avez fait le lendemain c'est
tout et c'est le lendemain et c'est un
film que j'appelais qu'ils après félix
le chat label fat man
et je me souviens toujours du titre et
le lendemain on était très timide on ne
parlait pas et le lendemain on s'est dit
on va se marier et je dis j ai dit mais
tu sais il faut prévenir les parents et
elle m'a répondu on leur dira quand on
sera mariée on a réuni tous les mômes du
village on est allé dans l'église du
village qu'elle s'était fait un petit
voile de mariée et on est rentré dans
l'église très sérieux et le curé nous a
vus arriver c'est caché il est venu voir
ma mère avec les larmes aux yeux du
mahdi et à dia ma merde c'est un peu un
des plus grands souvenirs de ma vie et
quand on est sortis de l'église
on est allé voir nos parents et on a dit
voilà on s'est marié le très beau comme
ça toi t'as un truc c'est que tu adores
faire la cour aux femmes en fait ça te
plaît un jeune séduire tu m as pas
jambes à les séduire
non papa m'aime pas c'est dur parce que
on arrive à une époque
oué
l'amour pour les jeunes c'est du sport
alors qu'il faut pas placer ça comme ça
d'abord il faut que ça soit
romantique même même si on on sait qu'on
n'aura aucune chance avec une femme
c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut être un
goujat ils sont prêts j'ai toujours été
prêt quand il voit juste raconter une
chose moi j'ai eu des aventures avec des
femmes
ils sont venus chez moi ils ont passé la
nuit à la maison et je me suis rendu
compte que pour me faire plaisir
elle voulait elle voulait faire l'amour
pour me faire plaisir
mais quelle 5 me disait rien du tout
mais je vends les toujours content et je
vous écoute chéri ne fatigue pas tu vas
me faire plaisir
mais si tu n'en as pas envie on s'arrête
là il passera une formule 1 tu as dit je
n'ai jamais essuyé deux refus de la part
d'une femme qui me plaisait jamais
jamais je veux dire la raison ouais et
il a raison c'est que je me rendais
compte que c'était pas la peine
d'insister
alors tu es marié quatre fois dont une
fois avec la même pour uvrer remarier
avec la même jeu avec arrivée à la
maison j'avais pas vu depuis deux ans et
puis elle me dit
voir jean j'ai fait une bêtise yakari
comme j'ai des moments formidables
on avait un enfant vous conviennent
ensemble et j'ai vu tellement malheur
j'ai dit pourquoi pas je savais que ça
allait je sais quand tu as eu des choses
assez grave non dans un coup très
difficile de deux dragons de recommencé
je lui ai dit écoute bon ben ya problème
et puis ça dure et que j'avais prévu
j'ai prévu est arrivé brigitte est un
pas que je dise mais c'est tellement
beau de toute façon brigitte et brigitte
elle m'a draguée avant le contraire de
moi un jour je sortais du théâtre et
était là
et puis eux
et elle vient vers moi elle me gâcher de
toutes vos pièces vous savez j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour vous
parce que j'ai lu toute votre vie
j'avais écrit un bouquin qui s'appelait
propres et ça n'arrive qu'à moi vous
êtes vous avec un homme roman depuis les
gens aiment en partie les communs comme
un homme peut paraître une femme
des hommes comme vous il y en a plus
beaucoup j'ai très touchée est très joli
très couture et puis elle se termine à
peine revenu régulièrement toutes les
semaines elle m'attendait à la sortie du
théâtre
et un jour
elle me laisse un petit mot
et elles savent et je double ali vous
lirez la lettre quand je fais partie et
est parti j'ai lu la lettre et l a dit
carrément dans la lettre à la fin
j'aimerais faire l'amour avec 10
[Musique]
super massa s'est pas prononcé non ça va
pas se salir lourd au sahara à savoir
aux jolies filles comme vous il sait
trop pourquoi voudriez m'aider ouais
vous savez le jeu ma part a divisé sa
cote serait la côte est avec moi oui oui
oui j'aime voir les choses et puis c'est
vrai elle est sacrée roulement ici alors
vous avez une belle couleur noire dont
je suis si vous êtes super bien
vous avez des yeux devlies
oh la la fernand ça vous plaise paris
j'avais une côte italienne
c'est vrai
je veux un bâtiment de guerre
la présidente est mme pastel des
calanques d'organes humains que des
portraits ou sait rien model kate moss
serait prêt à faire pour moi je suis un
tendre des belles choses
[Musique]
dis-moi dis-moi un truc comme ça jamais
fait ça ça c'est aux gens du sommeil la
tension est alors assuré un put alors je
suis encore dit ware dans une chambre
blanche avec moquette blanche cas sauf
acquis comme ça je te déshabille ouais
je prends une boîte de rouge à lèvres
cantine des rouges à lèvres ouais je me
mets du rouge à lèvres et je te couvre
le corps entier de baiser jusqu'à ce
qu'ils soient complètement rouge à
l'actuel
non c'est pas ça être couvertes y
dérogent à face car l'ami ring par les
lèvres du 2 mai
mais federica telemann comme des baisers
d'oiseaux y parvenir la chauffe du four
more et après les bébés je ressuscite un
pansement ou un peu immérité
là je fais des bisous des bisous des
bisous début
il faudra montrer ça ouais mais
grosse préparation avance préparation
grosse préparation avant l'introduction
comme comme un orchestre me racontent
souvent c'est beau c'est vous si tu le
désires attention ce n'est pas une
obligation
ce n'est pas une obligation il faut que
les deux parties soient d'accord pour la
chose d'humain non parce que je regarde
ça je suis pas le mec il dit bon je vous
vous et perd je vous emmènerai ici je
menais et puis se croient avoir tous les
droits
ouais ne pas se mouiller l'amour
romantique
mais sa vie n'est pas aussi bon que ça
sur j'en ai le coeur tout bouleverser
pas n'importe qui non unique pour moi
d'accord il voit tout sait lula mardi
opposant oui j'ai peur
ouais on consomme quand on met ce qu sur
le ban
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites je kiffe
monsieur répondez moi je suis donc point
d'écouté la conversation de la petite
cuillère de morceaux de subvention va
être passionnant c'est comme si je crois
qu'elle est tombée amoureuse de lui
et alors
où pourra-t-on se rencontrer lui
demande-t-elle dans un café lui répond
il
[Musique]
alors piccolo bonsoir reçoit partie sais
quoi dans la vie
je me réserve bien entendu ça rend
service parce que quand j'ai mené le
poisson c'est venu comme ça
ouais j'ai donné mes recettes les
recettes il ya toujours des herbes
écossais et les gens il faisait le tour
des centres venus on n'a rien trouvé
alors je me suis dit bon ben je faisais
encore la paire jeunes alors commencé à
arracher des herbes et je faisais car
mes clients et après j'ai arrêté je dis
maintenant je ne les veux et tu les
trouves au crb le fenouil
il ya un peu partout c'est pas comme les
autres je vais dans les affres de notre
province
ah bon je vais jusqu'au camp de kolda
l'eau gelée jusqu'à l'été dernier parce
que comme il lui a vu la sécheresse il
ya eu des problèmes et j'en ramassais
pas beaucoup parce que s'il fait sec sa
cause paraît il ya même des endroits
l'accord est complètement saturé ça
s'appelle comment c'est un métier
reconnu ça ab je sais pas s'il est
reconnu mais en france c'est une
tolérance
il ya beaucoup de retraités qui vendent
des aromates comme moi et qui payent pas
d'impôts moi ma femme forte et bien
entendu si le vent pas misère à joindre
les deux bouts
et croyez-moi ça vient pas tout seul est
ce que quand je ramassais désherbe j'ai
des risques
là il ya deux ans j'ai pris trois vies
père d'ali ben ouais l année dernière je
n'ai prévu non j'ai pas été mon but j'ai
eu de la chance
et puis j'ai été je suis les abeilles me
piquent des fois c'est pas mon bien mais
quand il ya des abeilles de solitude et
d'amérique a été piqué par une abeille
minutes j'avais les mains et puis ample
et ont été comme nous sommes bien et
j'étais au logis du ps est descendue à
fayence
je suis allé voir un docteur et docteur
maples une attention il va faire une
piqûre il m'a soigné ou les plumes
hospitalisé et 10 mois mais vipère les
plus dangereux c'est l'église c'est ça
l'église une petite a dit perreault
crise ça c'est plus dangereuse qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire si on se fait piquer
par une vipère des cadeaux ce public est
parvenu le père première des jeunes il
faut pas s'affoler il faut pas se parler
parce que je pouvais me porter la
matière mais il faut pas s'y fier là
dessus parce qu'il faut qu'il soit
toujours dans un frigo et s'il a pris la
chaleur et des jeunes filles là dessus
je crève alors il faut pas s'affoler
vous allez gentiment dans votre voiture
vous prenez votre voiture et vous allez
dans le village de l'eure le plus près
possible
on a d'ailleurs à moins que mon piqueurs
et l'augmentation humaine alors là on a
affaire de 2008 vous êtes au cas où ces
morts là ça va droit au coeur
ah ouais et c'est vrai qu'il faut su
c'est un peu le venin non oui il y en a
beaucoup qui le disent ça s'était vu
remettre deux temps
pour laisser comme ça y est on y perd le
moment si vous sucer le vous faites
comme chez vous ça fait une réaction
encore ça vous active il pourrait
tourner on ne pouvait seulement voyez
les plantes comme ça là je vois que ça
il faut que je me dise est une sas a des
propriétés médicinales
c'est pas trop romantique soins oui oui
ça c'est une plante que c'était nous
venons nous fait nous autrement dit si
vous êtes ballot mais s'avoue un peu
passé et si vous allez l'adorer ça vous
la fait passer les si vous êtes constipé
aussi 10 en hongrie les deux extrêmes et
l'origan leur égard ça fait quoi
brigand c'est le ruban du déficit c'est
un désinfectant de bronze
voyons ça c'est très très bon voyez vous
pour les bras il faut comprendre comment
l'origan ont fait des infusions à voyez
vous oui et puis après vous avez là
semble aussi que c'est très bon sens et
la sarriette et c'est très beau et ça
tue les microbes qu'on peut avoir d'un
estomac s'appuient les microbes
solutions et metz à la sarriette on
appelle ça loupé vraie dérive parce que
dans les pizzas il avait des milliers
mais il faut traduire le poivre d âne il
faut traduire pour voir les photos du
brésil en français ça veut dire le
poivre de 101 et l'horizon de la série
est si bon chemin
partout il y en a ça plus papa est bien
entendu car on ne pouvait plus marcher
un bourricot la 85 kg et le fait il a
fait un moteur km un peu plus il peut
plus marcher qui rompent la pâte
alors il arrache 16 ans pour que ces
journées le cul entre bernard les aides
alors voyez ça c'est finalement qu'ils
connaissaient leur est remboursé par la
sécurité sociale mais justement de la
super légers
alors voyez je suis choquée qui a la
moitié des français et des françaises
qui ne savent pas ce que c'est le thème
mettez y à quoi ça sert mais qu'est ce
que c'est le thème viens mettez vous
savez c'est bon pour le foie c'est bon
pour beaucoup de choses en main et bien
figurez ouvre quand on est malade
si les gens savaient parce que là je
vais demander au ministre de l'éducation
de faire une heure de cours botanique
pour les jeunes qui étudient
oui parce que c'est pas possible ça et
sur le plan aphrodisiaques a b c est ce
qu on peut faire selon l'ordinateur au
10e
voilà en fait des petits plateaux et ça
c'est formidable et jean ba s'est en
effet oui sûrement il ya notamment que
lehman a acheté début peut-être deux
jours après elle m'a dit qu'elle a
commencé à incendier ici la palme du
second pan de l'enduit tout n'était pas
pour pouvoir des aphrodisiaques
j'ai pris ça pour mon mari qu'il était
très faiblard et tout frais comme me
l'avait donné dix ans bon le matin
boulevard je vous avais dit alors on me
dit vous comprenez c'est un homme
sérieux maintenant que fait la cour à la
bande
olala mais ça marche ça là bas je te
pose est là est ce que toi piccolo tu
t'en sers de ton cocktail afro design on
and on est pourquoi comme j'avais 20 ans
on n'a pas besoin je faisais l'amour une
fois ouais je faisais l'amour de poids
je m'endormais la tête sur ce match je
dormais tout l'après midi un vin
d'honneur a promis une fois ça me
réveille au report
[Musique]
ceux qui croyaient qu'il faut coucher
pour réussir
non
pourquoi parce que l'avenir appartient à
ceux qui se lèvent tôt monsieur mais
pourquoi
et parce que demain ils se marient
monsieur
[Musique]
non
ne me touches je tension
vicky deux mois
je ne fais plus plus ils vont
avec une autre se partager d'ailleurs
l'apa
tu te bats
[Musique]
argent
les chenilles
hélas
toute légalité mon grand
[Musique]
arrête arrête tu me touche pas je t'en
supplie
fé pitié de moi d'écouter ma se pose
je suis prêt
suivant la loi mais
tu attends et ferrer
dans un an
[Applaudissements]
à la place
et pour garder
missiaen
des années nous
[Musique]
je sais je sais de même encore
comme toi
plus fort ils avaient plus le temps
pour garantir
[Musique]
unis
à
ça
[Musique]
les soirs nous laisse pantois
si tu es
démare 2
harry
c'est elle qui aura le confort chez moi
avec mon corps
chez elle
va te dis
si tu veux
grisé ce soir ce soir là
iroquois
[Musique]
ce pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier j'ai pas dit non
et
alors patricia carli bonsoir alors
c'était ok l'année cette chanson soit
5.7 chanson qui s'appelle en fait demain
tu te maries et que tout le monde
appelle reine la reine ne me touche pas
parce que finalement le refrain qu'on
célèbre le couple et non c'est vrai
qu'il a écrite 700 sa création s'est
passé comment qu'il a écrites dans
quelles circonstances s'est inspiré
d'une histoire vraie louis voilà voilà
exact c'est est amoureuse d'un titre
voilà sa flamme était en vacances voilà
et il m'avait dit qu'il était séparé de
sa femme et patati patata et que la
raison en est que la halle est rentré de
vacances
djourou humanis âge j'ai eu d'angoise le
soir je vais pas briser un couple
je ne voulais pas je disais bon mais je
vais laisser tomber qui reste avec sa
femme et et le soir je me suis mis à
pleurer dans ma chambre il a pris la
guitare et surtout ça alors en fait
tomber non ce n'est pas du tout patricia
carli non c'est rosetta hargitt hardy
habitante après tu as pris patricia
pourquoi et c'était la mode où on avait
des non plus non plus un psy chic et
carly ça vient d'eux carlini c'est un
héros du feuilleton quand tu étais petit
que lisez ma maman et ma cachette d'elle
quand elle n'était pas là j'ai essayé de
lire ce feuilleton et c'était le héros
le playback les cars mini et je rêvais
de rentrer monsieur je suis dit si je
devais un jour une grande vedette je
m'appellerai carlini comme et maurice
est à dire sans les sacs a dit non non
c'est que les rencontres et après quand
j'étais célèbre heidi bon j'ai rien
contre
ils étaient au moins on pouvait le voir
j'étais amoureuse folle de lit du malade
et si oui alors tu en fais tu es à tuer
la fille d'un immigré italien qui était
mineur en belgique
oui et des tons plus jeune âge tu
voulais chanter c'était son truc oui
c'était pas vraiment moi c'est quand
j'étais petite fille en italie j'avais 4
ans on en avait fait chanter dans une
église en amputant vous à l'avé maria
dans les autres sports après tu as fait
des quantités d'audition wit fm denis à
paris et j'ai fait un peu jeté par tout
est venu à paris et direct a fait deux
ans la vaisselle pour bouffer quand tu
arrives appareils oui tu la faisait ou
la vaisselle dans un restaurant clichy
où je gagnais 15 francs par jour
je croyais
900 francs d'hôtel il restait six femmes
opprimées ranger pascal autres dans les
restaurants mais j'ai quand même moins
jusqu'au jour à comment ça s'est passé
j'avais j'avais été prévue dans deux
lycées édition et on m'avait dit dans un
mois ou d'un contrat puis une autre
mardi dans quinze jours et puis dans une
édition on a fait venir quelqu'un chez
barclay qui lui m'a dit de mais j'ai
aussi une contrat alors moi je croyais
qu'à cette époque là quand une idée
qu'on avait des sous si vous arrivez
encore ans j'ai signé le contrat qui
j'ai attendu que les vacances effacé à
la rentrée
enregistrez vous avez quel âge à
l'époque 17 alors après tu as fait des
tournées taper des voyages beaucoup de
voyages partout et puis tu as eu des
problèmes avec ton mec parce que tu es
jaloux de toi c'est ça non dire qu'il
voulait que c'est un homme ou une femme
on essaie de les bus
toujours quelqu'un pour le déduire donc
il fallait que je sois une vedette pour
que parce qu'ils s'occupaient des
artistes vous l'êtes bien et fort qu'une
grande vedette pour lui puis quand
j'étais trop vedette savent ennuyés
parce que c'était trop et un beau jour
il m'a dit bon retard est maintenant ça
suffit
qu est ce que c est que certains moments
et collecter du succès puis après
trouver comme avait trop j'en avais
voilà à l'égard de son but et c'était
compliqué quand très très amoureuse de
lui
j'ai arrêté j'ai dit ce que pas rester
comme ça que j'écris mon moi pour cadiou
c'est waouh c'est moi oui dur ça quand
même
ouais ouais je l'avais que commencer à
ce moment là j'ai une grosse déception
puis je me suis dit en faisant des
champions ça m'était parce que moi ce
qui comptait c'était je chantais quand
je faisais mes maquettes pour les autres
donc je pouvais encore chanter en
achètent d'autres mais là tu t'es mis à
écrire pour les autres
ouais et l'attaqué des trucs s'entasser
qu'a écrit oh lady mary pour david
alexandre winter
quand tu as écrit aussi des chansons
pour mireille mathieu par exemple avec
lui pardonne moi ce caprice d'enfant
qu'il est très très bien marché et ça
comme ça tout seul paroles et musique
avec ta guitare chez toi oui cet
instinct ouais vous en fais pas beaucoup
c'est alors comme ça après donc on a un
vrai talent oui oui j'ai j'y peux rien
c'est n'est pas comme ça ça sent bien
tout seul pas toujours pas souvent mais
quand son bien samedi
report a écrit pourquoi de françois
était écrit la tendresse pour des
guichard non personne ne sait que c'est
en effet ça fait très mal au retour
et puis là c'est la merde à ce moment là
ça commence a mal tourné avec ans jules
on peut pas dire que ça s'arrangera
venir tu divorces tu perds ta mère à ce
moment là mon chien donc je suis à qui
avait 16 ans marlène
j'ai eu ce cancer l'idiot en plus dans
deux mois de passe son bac
à vrai dire surtout quand on sert tous l
es là tu dégringole quoi henri
complètement savez les mouvements sont
complets et donc je me suis obligée
après à rechanter dans les discothèques
et compagnie parce qu'il fallait que je
gagne ma vie qui m'a fait grand plaisir
mais j'étais malade tu tente un come
back à un moment c'est en 79 oui avec
une chanson qui s'appelait l'homme sur
la plage ça marche pas mal
ouais ça marche même très bien parce que
j'étais après les bee gees la deuxième
banque de russie aux russes de pierre et
la thur tombe malade encore tu rechute
quoi mouais oui bon et après a fallu
continuer la vie est obligé tout arrêter
pour soigner à ce moment oui je suis
parti je veux dix dents
eh bien tu vends ta maison tu achète un
appartement au soleil c'est là s'était
installé au cap d'agde taqwa laban
appartement ouais je partais retrouver
le sud un peu oui comme tu es d'origine
italienne a un peu retrouvé ses racines
j'adore mon monaco beaucoup car j'adore
les preuves je rêve devant eux et je
suis jusqu'à la frontière belge et leur
château devant moi j'aurai tout le temps
et j'adore ce coin là c'est vrai que
c'est formidable
alors dis moi tu l'as vécu comme en font
ce changement de situation c'est à dire
de passer d'une finalement d'été stark
était connu et puis d'un seul coup bah
tu te retrouves au cap d'ail dans son
appartement labat de faire des courses
le matin les gens ne reconnaissent pas
obligatoirement vous verrez comment il
c'est pas ça qui viennent vraiment c'est
de se sentir abandonné de tout le monde
moi j'ai reçu tout paris chez moi je
tout le monde voulait venir j'ai aidé
d'aidés d'état de 2,2 chanteur auteur
compositeur et c'est pas que je voulais
l'appareil sait que dans un moment comme
ça on a envie d'entendre quelqu'un qui
vous répondent qui dit attendant la tête
prendre un cachet d'aspirine ça fait du
bien
j'avais plus ma mère pour l'appeler
parce qu'avant je me voulait sur ma mère
maman faisait bêta ma chérie pandémie
pourquoi à ton avis j'ai jamais devenu
une énorme star qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans ta vie qu'elle a été là la
chose qui affecte et jamais devenu une
énorme star comme a pu être mireille
mathieu comme intelligent et bien
c'était mon mari en fait c'est c'est
l'amour qui t'a fait réussir et c'est
l'amour qui te fait jouer j'ai réussi
pour lui et c'est lui qui m'a fait
échouer
[Musique]
c'est safran c'est bon ça normalement si
17 balles mais mois après bon j'vous
restos j'ai besoin de boire un coup avec
une gamine j'ai des frais quoi c'est bon
c'est bon parce est passé est passé
alors deux adultes un chien 53 disent
quoi et usa ne peut rien que ça bonjour
voulez vous mettre à poil
d'accord vous allez vous faire [__] ou
pas non c'est parce que c'est un
supplément si vous faites monter sur la
plage alors d'accord
maintenant je regarde le défi renoncer à
vous regarder
[Musique]
[__] c'est quoi ces dindes
mais alors là j'ai jamais vu ça
voilà non mais là non allez-y combien de
jours vous êtes chez marcel fait
attention
faites attention
non c'est pas ça c'est que marcel a un
fils qui a été dans un hôpital
psychiatrique pendant 15 ans il est
sorti hier il a assassiné des touristes
qui dormait à la ferme il a été 15 ans
en hôpital psychiatrique il est rentré
hier donc la nuit vous fermer la porte à
clé
d'accord parce que ce serait con là il
est rentré hier ce serait con qu un
couple comme vous égorgez la nuit rendez
compte ils séparation moi jamais je
serai dans le match nul j'aime attendait
mais marcel il est sympa mais le fils je
les ai vus ne voulait pas vu rôder là
c'est la nuit qui sort sur tout va ils
s'enferment dans la chambre la journée
il au premier fermez bien
amel et anti les ouvre avec son que
terre
on y est
de quoi
un couple il ya 15 ans qu'au début de
quand ils ont ouvert ou au camping à la
ferme quand les premières années il a
égorgé un couple de hollandais
il est il a violé la voiture à vendre il
a égorgé le couple de hollandais et des
malades ces mecs je sais de quoi je
parle c'est mon frère alors est malade
il est sorti et on verra un faut virer
ce soir s'il est guéri
allez bonne bourre je suis content nous
dira connais je pourrais le dire aux
journalistes bercy il a expliqué mme
glyphes layton ait phoque your mother
it's my first le sun is good ofac my
mother mais tu fuck you think you think
you would suck my geek
non ok secondes noces en asie tokyo
ok alors à bon c'est connu c'est non et
ce à quoi il fait une émission le
dimanche soir
comment tisser thierry ardisson qui
dirige les missions et oui il fait
partie de l'émission
non mais c'est pas une blague raciste et
puis si c'est ça fait deux fois qu'on me
dise à cette semaine bien thériault il
fait du micro-trottoir commandes ils
interrogent des gens il leur pose des
questions d'ailleurs se plaît pas
toujours aux jambes en charbon se sait
quelque chose
mais vous lui ressemblez vraiment rien
pour semblait alors en bas si ce qu'on
m'a dit ils font des saisies t2 tu
devrais aller faire le sosie on l'a déjà
dit ça il est sympa ce mec
[Musique]
on m'a dit que c'est un connard un peu
trop directe mal embouché vous dites
madame pipi jeu froid oui je crois que
alors par nature il serait un peu
prétentieux c'est un petit monsieur je
crois quel connard ces mec de la télé je
supporte pas ça on m'a dit qu'ils aient
des prétentieux et moi elle m'a dit ces
mecs là il faut trois émissions ils
prennent la grosse tête un peu et c'est
un mec arrogant
on m'a dit dans la vie c'est vrai je
ressemble mais vraiment sur les lunettes
ou vraiment ça se trouve c'est moi ça se
trouve un vous tendiez de quoi vous le
cola prétentieux c'est moi voilà la
caméra là bas c'était moi oui ça fait
six mois si l'auteur c'est moi
vous êtes au moins peu à vous souvenir
de ce spa du le supplice caussadais
j'aime j'aime j'aime j'aime ses genoux
devrais je m'en fous vous appelez ça non
plus en plus bas c'est normal
eh bien il avait la relève le défi de
faire une reprise encore plus
extraordinaire c'est celle ci isabelle
adjani moniot en anglais cette fois
[Musique]
m
martin
allez vous
ah ah
[Musique]
j'aime
m
un chalet
chez les
non
[Musique]
eric et nos chefs
tu
mason
non
[Musique]
j'aime
mais
[Musique]
chez
m
[Musique]
j'aime
j'ai
les chaînes
[Musique]
m
d'autre part
un chien
nos chiens
dieu
[Musique]
hamon
tous
j
[Musique]
enfin jacky qu'est ce que c'est que cet
accoutrement ça ne se discute pas
monsieur quand l'esprit mesure le corps
lui doit son but à ce propos il vous
arrive de faire la moue rejeté une fois
tous les six ans et demi n'avait pas de
femme jackie jeu ce n'est pas parce
qu'on n'a pas de femme qu'on n'a pas de
fin poussifs et jeudi c'est ce soir
monsieur
andré bonsoir alors les livres de la
semaine alors mon petit gars ça va mon
petit gars bien si je te dis mon petit
gars c'est évidemment que je te parle
comme serge dassault
parce que bâillon ces deux journées de
libération a fait paraître un livre qui
s'appelle gazon maudit ce pays c es et
ses livres qu'il faut lire parce que
c'est là l'intégralité de deux
interviews immense que bâillon a fait
avec un sourire plein ou serge
gainsbourg en 80 et 20 de 10 ans avant
sa mort disais je suis mort voilà ce qui
m'arrive est celle d'un gainsbourg
d'élire un gazouillis minant etc
et puis un autre interview sur les
femmes l'amour là mort tu es là si tu
veux ce qui est formidable dans ce
bouquin ces convois de gainsbourg était
avant tout un moraliste cher que ce type
us s ou le cynisme sous le côté les
femmes sous le côté amateur hachiko vam
ont fusé répétitions tous côtés tu sais
du gamin qui dit ouais ouais regardez
moi je suis le meilleur je suis plus
fort because messesinfo schumann your
hands are de rest of the rest of the
beast tout le folklore gainsbourg à un
moment donné parce que bâillon est un
excellent interviewer ce cas ce qu'ont
montré un gaz bourg non seulement
fragile mais un gainsbourg au fond c'est
un grand sentimental qui est un type qui
tient à morales qui tient les tic qui
tient a fallu y parle de ses filles de
charlotte tout ça tu le sens
complètement papa gâteau gâteau et il
est complètement émouvant dans ce livre
dans le même temps alors il dit des
énormités tous ses fantasmes avec les
femmes toutes ces histoires et tu senti
le gainsbourg qui a été très humilié
parce qu'il était petit lait au début
par les femmes rejeté et vit à je me
suis mangé il parle d'une princesse par
exemple qui n'avait pas voulu de lui et
puis vint après le réduit et je les
baisers puis de les renvoyer du moment
il ya toute la revanche avec la vie et
même temps c'est complètement tendre
gainsbourg n'est pas mort et c'est
surtout pas vicieux et l'autre libre
alors c'est un livre vraiment de
vacances que j'ai beaucoup aimée qui est
un livre d'amour de lionel chouchon qui
s'appelle 35 degrés de latitude nord
alors ça c'est une histoire qui a dû
arriver un peu plus d'hommes s'est marié
avec des enfants 20 ans de mariage tout
va bien ça va et puis un jour rencontre
le bureau de communication et rencontre
une superbe pouces et il est là et il
tombe complètement pâmoison elle aussi
court drap apache sexuelle accéléré
alors comment cela l'on complet dalle
ultérieure pour tout le monde depuis des
siècles je cache dix pages et des
séminaires ma chérie je peux pas rentrer
ce soir on pas trop tôt etc
et puis alors ils te raconte tout ça ce
qui a secure cette sempiternelle
histoire d'adultère et après il se
sépare de sa femme depuis vit avec avec
cette fille qui est il le raconte avec
beaucoup d'humour avec beaucoup de
tendresse et il trace en fait un
portrait à la fois des cadres de la
france d'aujourd'hui et puis de cette
baisse de marivaudage amoureux dans
laquelle beaucoup de gens ont sombré
alors que celui qui n'a jamais péché lui
jette la première pierre
en tout cas c'est un livre qui se
déroule gouttes plaisir qui se disent de
demain d'ailleurs pas seulement nous ne
joue pas du tout à fait charmant est il
à ce grand prix ménages ont moins de
faire rire tout le tout et dopage et
dans ces affaires là qui sont
quelquefois douloureuse il est bon de
rire d'ailleurs il est toujours bon noël
[Applaudissements]
non
et
ah ah
[Musique]
à
bonsoir merci d'avoir passé cette soirée
avec nous au bar de la plage prochaine
ouverture samedi prochain salut bande de
nazes
[Musique]
à
on
oh
douala
ah ah
[Musique]
oh
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
à
[Musique]
oh
m
ah ah
[Musique]
oh
au grand jeu félix bar de la plage la
question est et quel est le vrai nom de
patricia carli et la réponse
rosetta ardito
[Musique]
vous avez gagné le baladeur cd phillips
à télécommande programmation possible
jusqu'à 20 plages bravo
antenne 2 et philips vous ont présenté
le bar de la plage
l'émission d'été de thierry ardisson et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu